here along the Mississippi River between
New Orleans and Baton Rouge is an 85
mile stretch of land known as cancer
alley for decades some communities
living in this part of Louisiana have
reported disproportionately high rates
of respiratory diseases and cancer in
one part of a parish called Saint John
the Baptist a person's lifetime risk of
getting cancer is 50 times greater than
that of the average American and now it
also has one of the highest kovat 19
death rates per capita in the country a
closer look reveals that the community
here is predominantly black and that
figures into an alarming pattern across
the country black people are dying at
disproportionate rates compared to their
populations while there are many
historical and structural inequalities
at play one part of the problem may be
lurking in the air
Louisiana has some of the most toxic air
in the u.s. for decades
oil gas chemicals and plastics have been
manufactured here much of it comes from
the roughly 200 chemical plants and oil
refineries which got this corridor on
the banks of the Mississippi River they
call it cancer alley they are afraid
that
the very air that I'm breathing right
now is so filled with carcinogens that
they have labeled the river area a
national sacrifice zone the industry
emits dozens of different chemicals that
are known to cause cancer along with
something called PM 2.5 which causes
fine particle pollution when exposed to
it these tiny particles just a fraction
of the width of a human hair can lodge
deep in our lungs and bloodstream and
can lead to health problems like heart
disease asthma and lung cancer the
Environmental Protection Agency's
estimates of cancer risk from air
toxicity are far higher in this region
than much of the rest of the country and
they follow the path of the
petrochemical industry but even within
these high-risk areas here along the
Mississippi and across the country these
risks are not distributed equally among
communities one EPA analysis found that
black people are exposed to about 1.5
times more particle pollution than white
people
for example even though Saint John the
Baptist is 58 percent black the
community closest to this chemical plant
is 92 percent black this is real that's
Robert Bullard who's been researching
urban planning and environmental policy
for decades and has written 18 books on
it history this country is tied to race
and in place here along cancer alley the
history of the communities goes back to
slavery
this map shows that the area used to be
mostly sugar plantations after slavery
ended many free black people stayed in
the area and established black
communities on or near plantations like
these others continued to be exploited
through a system called sharecropping
where white plantation owners gave black
farmers access to land in exchange for a
portion of their crop as rent
landowners often manipulated prices to
make a profit while pushing black
laborers into debt and poverty the
practice continued for nearly a century
until the 1940s when a new industry took
off in Louisiana and petrochemical
plants started replacing these
plantations they were invited into the
state and into the corridor
without the permission of the people who
live closest these many decisions were
made when when people of color didn't
have representatives companies set up
their facilities right next to the
historically black communities but most
of the jobs at the plants didn't go to
them and the community is left with
pollution poverty and sickness and in
some cases death corporations often
bought out entire towns like here in
reveal town where the Georgia Gulf
corporation bought out the town and
today they're still a historically black
cemetery within the grounds of a
chemical plant power and money dictate
where things go that other people don't
want that's how we end up right now with
all of these we call it sacrifice on
these places that are over polluted have
more than their fair share of poverty
and sicknesses toxic industries have
been established near communities of
color across the u.s. like mining
operations and power plants on a nearer
Native American reservations and in more
urban areas racist public policies like
redlining have historically marked black
and brown neighborhoods as less
desirable pushing polluters like
highways and factories closer to their
homes zip code is still the most potent
predictor of health and well-being you
tell me your zip code I can tell your
health you are and I can tell you what's
in your neighborhood and what's not in
your neighborhood one analysis of eight
cities shows residents of historically
red lined neighborhoods live with
significantly higher levels of air
pollution and
are more than twice as likely as their
peers to visit emergency rooms for
asthma today the research draws a strong
connection between history and health
and how even now 80 years after these
maps were drawn they still play a role
and not just where people live but how
healthy they are you get this
heat-seeking missile that is targeting
that is zeroing in community and and
when it targets that community what we
end up is a death bomb the health
problems that air pollution exposure can
lead to like heart and respiratory
diseases are the same underlying
conditions that can make coronavirus
much more dangerous one preprint study
made a clear link between air pollution
and more severe coronavirus cases by
analyzing over 3000 US counties and
controlling for certain factors they
found that counties with higher
exposures to air pollution also had
higher probabilities of deadly
coronavirus cases in their analysis a
small increase in long-term exposure to
air pollution led to a large increase in
the kovat 19 death rate and although we
should be cautious with this preliminary
data the findings underscore a possible
reason why the corona virus has been
particularly deadly in black communities
in louisiana black residents make up 32
percent of the population but they made
up 56% of Cova 19 deaths and in Michigan
14 percent of the population but 41
percent of deaths the corona virus is
actually bringing to the surface what
many of us have known for me to use
people already have all these underlying
conditions because of where they live
because of not having access to health
care because not having health insurance
not having you know the kinds of things
that make people healthy in terms of the
environment and so it is not surprising
it's it's disappointing and it makes you
angry in March the Trump administration
suspended clean air protections across
the country so in Louisiana's cancer
alley
that means petrochemical facilities will
now have no oversight over how much they
pollute and even though we are just
starting to learn about the connections
between pollution exposure and severe
coronavirus outcomes it's a move that
ignores the history and research that
precedes it of how segregation pollution
and health in black communities are
inextricably linked
[Music]
[Music]